they've had enough of isis on their land
and are determined to drive them out
[Music]
this is going to be a long day it's old
style fighting
men replacing men on the barricade a
constant barrage from both sides
commanders issuing orders as isis
fighters tried to outmaneuver them
the first proper offensive on isis is
underway
rockets artillery and machine guns pound
their positions from a ridgeline
the kurds are still softening them up
but these are hardcore isis fighters
foreign and iraqi and you think there's
chechens in there there is there is yeah
in
india there was a iraqi military post
that got abandoned three days ago and we
have sources there and they moved a
group of afghans into that fort uh you
have chechens uh
our guys didn't know obviously what they
were they're like they're they have uh
blonde beers and blue eyes you know and
uh
they have teams of sniper they're very
organized they have teams of snipers
they have teams with heavy guns
so we'll slowly slowly try and
miss our show
the brigade commander has been
negotiating with tribal elders to give
up the foreign fighters but they've
reneged on a deal
so the next phase starts inside yolula
itself
urban warfare is the most dangerous
isis gunmen are firing from all sides
well the kurds have pushed their way
into town they push the isis
uh fighters away there's reports that
they're bringing in a reinforcement the
fighting is just around
the street corner just about 200 meters
away from here
[Applause]
there's fighting everywhere sometimes
meters away in towns
you can really see who is where
a man comes from enemy positions as he's
led away they put down warning shots to
deter
sniper fire but every crossing point now
is dangerous
families trying to escape the fighting
have to walk through the battle lines to
safety
as the battle intensifies the kurds up
the ante tanks deploying
around the isis positions
are determined to win here the tanks
have reinvigorated their morale
there's a lot more fighting to come
stuart ramsey sky news